So the true meaning of absolute value is the distance from 0. Let's take a
closer look at this. If I had the absolute value of 6, I would want to know the
distance of 6 from 0. Okay here's a number line, here's 0 and here's 6. If I
count the distance from 0 to 6, I know I got 1, 2,3 4, 5, 6. So 6 is 6 units
away from 0. So the absolute value of 6 is 6. For negative 9, I want to find the
distance of negative 9 from 0. Here's 0, and here's negative 9. If I count the
distance or units from 0 to negative 9, I know that I'll go 9 units all
together. So this distance is 9. The absolute value of negative 9 is positive 9.
For absolute value, I know that the absolute value will always be positive. I'm
referring to distance.